♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THINGS HAVE CHANGED SO FAST, SO
DRAMATICALLY THIS YEAR THAT IT’S
HARD TO REMEMBER WHAT A VERY
DIFFERENT COUNTRY THIS WAS ON
NEW YEAR’S MORNING.
BACK THEN, A LITTLE OVER SEVEN
MONTHS AGO, THE U.S. FELT
POLITICALLY VOLATILE.
THERE WAS AN ELECTION COMING.
BUT IT’S STILL FUN FUNDAMENTALLY
AMERICAN.
THERE WAS NO MISTAKING THIS
COUNTRY FOR ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
WE WERE NOT MEXICO OR BAROODY.
WE DEFINITELY WANT
TO CHINA.
YES, MOST OF OUR GOODS WERE
MANUFACTURED IN ASIA BUT OUR WAY
OF LIFE, OUR SYSTEM AND SOCIETY
SEEM TO BE THE VERY OPPOSITE OF
CHINA.
THE CHINESE WERE ENSLAVED.
WE WERE FREE.
THAT WAS THE DIFFERENCE AND IT
WAS PERMANENT.
IT WOULD NEVER CHANGE.
NOT ONE AND A THOUSAND AMERICANS
DOUBTED THAT.
IN JANUARY, DR. ANTHONY FATTY AT
THE TIME, NOT YET A HOUSEHOLD
NAME, DID AN INTERVIEW TO TALK
ABOUT AMERICA’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SERGEY EXPLAINED THE
AUTHORITARIAN MEASURES THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAD TAKEN TO
CONTAIN THAT VIRUS.
THEN DR. FAUCI NOTED THAT AN
AMERICAN OUT OF THAT WOULD BE
ALLOWED.
WATCH.
>> THEY HAVE NOT ONLY SHUT OUT
TRAFFIC OUT OF WUHAN, PLAYS,
TRUCKS, BUSES, FAIRIES, RAIL,
BUT THEY’VE DONE IT TO A NUMBER
OF SURROUNDING CITIES, SO
RATHER THAN SAY HISTORICALLY, IT
DOESN’T DO MUCH GOOD, WHICH IS
TRUE, I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT
TO WAIT AND SEE THAT MAY BE THE
CHINESE, BECAUSE OF THE STATE OF
THEIR SOCIETY, THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, THERE’S NO
CHANCE IN THE WORLD THAT WE
COULD DO THAT TO CHICAGO OR TO
NEW YORK OR TO SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Tucker: AS YOU WELL KNOW,
THERE IS NO CHANCE IN THE WORLD
THAT WE COULD DO THAT TO CHICAGO
OR TO NEW YORK OR TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT IS WHAT FAUCI SAID.
NOTE HIS USE OF THE WORD "TOO."
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WAS DOING
THE CHINESE MIKE THINGS TO ITS
PEOPLE.
NOT FOR THEM.
NONE OF THAT WOULD EVER BE
ALLOWED HERE IN A FREE COUNTRY.
IT JUST COULDN’T HAPPEN IN
AMERICA.
FAUCI HIMSELF HAS SINCE BECOME
ONE OF THE MOST STRIDENT
ADVOCATES OF THE CHINESE
RESPONSE FOR CORONAVIRUS, BUT
HE’S HARDLY ALONE IN THAT.
YESTERDAY, THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK
ANNOUNCED HE PLANS TO ERECT
ARMED CHECKPOINTS AROUND THE
PERIMETER OF THE CITY AND USE
GOVERNMENT AGENTS TO FOLLOW
CITIZENS TO THEIR HOMES.
IT WOULD’VE BEEN IMPOSSIBLE TO
IMAGINE ANY OF THAT IN JANUARY.
AT de BLASIO’S ANNOUNCEMENT
DIDN’T SEEM ESPECIALLY
SHOCKING, WE ARE USED TO IT.
THAT IS HOW SIMILAR TO CHINA WE
HAVE BECOME.
IT’S A BIG CHANGE.
BUT LIKE ALL SEISMIC SHIFTS, IT
HAPPENED INCREMENTALLY BEFORE IT
HAPPENED OVERNIGHT.
FOR YEARS, WE WATCHED OUR
LEADERS PROSTRATE THEMSELVES
BEFORE THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
MOST ASSUMED THEY WERE GREEDY,
THAT IS WHY THEY WERE DOING IT.
CHINA WAS PAYING THEIR BILLS SO
THEY BOWED.
WE NEVER IMAGINED THEY ACTUALLY
ADMIRED THE CHINESE SYSTEM.
OH, BUT THEY DID.
AND THAT BECAME CLEAR WITH THE
ARRIVAL OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE FIRST STEP WAS THEIR
RESOLUTE REFUSAL TO ADMIT WHERE
THE VIRUS CAME FROM.
WHEN STRONG EVIDENCE EMERGED
FROM CHINESE SCIENTISTS THAT THE
DISEASE ORIGINATED IN A LAB IN
WUHAN, OUR LEADERS IMMEDIATELY
AND ADAMANTLY DISMISSED IT AS A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THEY DIDN’T WANT TO KNOW MORE.
THEIR FIRST INSTINCT WAS TO
DEFEND CHINA.
THEY DIDN’T WANT THE CHINESE
SYSTEM DISCREDITED.
THAT SEEMED CONFUSING, BUT WE
SOON LEARNED WHY.
THE DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL
ACTIVIST ZEKE EMANUEL WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST TO REVEAL HOW THE
LEFT’S PLAN TO USE THE PANDEMIC
TO CHANGE THE UNITED STATES.
HERE HE IS ON MSNBC FOUR MONTHS
AGO THIS WEEK.
>> REALISTICALLY, COVID-19 WILL
BE HERE FOR THE NEXT 18 MONTHS
OR MORE.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY UNTIL WE FIND A VACCINE
OR EFFECTIVE MEDICATIONS.
IT IS ALL THAT ECONOMIC PAIN
WORTH TRYING TO STOP COVID-19?
THE TRUTH IS WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> Tucker: OH, THE TRUTH IS WE
HAVE NO CHOICE.
EXCEPT, IN A DEMOCRACY, WE
ALWAYS HAVE A CHOICE.
THAT’S WHY IT’S DIFFERENT FROM
AN AUTOCRACY.
IN A DEMOCRACY, ON THE BIG
QUESTIONS, THE PUBLIC GETS TO
DECIDE WHAT THE PUBLIC WANTS.
THE PEOPLE RULE.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
BUT THE LEFT HAD NO PLANS TO LET
THE PUBLIC DECIDE ANYTHING.
SO INSTEAD, THEY ISSUED RESOLUTE
DECREES, REMAIN AT HOME.
WEAR A MASK, DO NOT CONGREGATE
WITH OTHERS.
NO ONE ASKED VOTERS WHAT THEY
THOUGHT ABOUT ANY OF THIS.
DEMOCRACY PLAYED NO ROLE IN IT.
MEN WITH GUNS AND FORCED THE
ORDERS, GOVERNMENT USED ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY TO TRACK DOWN ANYONE
WHO DOES A BAD THEM.
JUST LIKE IN CHINA.
HERE’S ERIC GARCETTI.
SPEAK OF THIS HAS REALLY BEEN
MARVELOUSLY EMBRACED BY 99.9% OF
PEOPLE, WE SEE IT IN THE
TRACKING DATA, THE CELL PHONE
DATA BUT WE ARE GOING TO HUNT
DOWN THE LAST .1% AND SAY, YOU
GOT TO GET INSIDE, AND YOU’VE
GOT TO DISTANCE.
>> Tucker: MOST PEOPLE OBEY
BUT "WE ARE GOING TO HUNT DOWN
THE LAST 1%.
IN OTHER WORDS, NO DISSENT OF
ANY KIND ALOUD, JUST LIKE IN
CHINA.
IN CHINA, THEY LOAD DISOBEDIENT
CITIZENS INTO TRUCKS AND CART
THEM AWAY.
WE HAVE VIDEO OF THAT HAPPENING.
IN LOS ANGELES, THEY JUST STARVE
YOU OUT.
THEY TAKE AWAY YOUR WATER AND
ELECTRICITY.
>> THESE LARGE PARTIES ARE
UNSAFE AND COULD COST ANGELENOS
THEIR LIFE.
THAT IS QUITE AN ITEM
AUTHORIZING THE CITY TO SHUT OFF
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER
AND POWER SERVICE IN THE
EGREGIOUS CASES IN WHICH HOUSES,
BUSINESSES, AND OTHER VENUES ARE
HOSTING UNPERMITTED LARGE
GATHERINGS.
>> Tucker: RECOGNIZED THAT?
IN SOME WAYS, ALL AUTHORITARIAN
SOCIETIES ARE THE SAME.
THEY ARE CHARACTERIZED BY
CORRUPTION, A LACK OF SOCIAL
TRUST, AND A DEEP CYNICISM ABOUT
GOVERNMENT.
ALL OF THOSE ARE ENDEMIC IN
CHINA.
SUDDENLY, THERE ARE NEARLY
UNIVERSAL IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THAT OUR
LEADERS ARE LYING TO US.
POLITICIANS USE A LOCKDOWNS FOR
POLITICAL ENDS.
IN THE NAME OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THEY REWARD SUPPORTERS AND
PUNISH THEIR OPPONENT.
THEY ARE BARELY HIDING THIS
ANYMORE.
THEY’VE DONE IT SINCE DAY ONE
BUT MOST OF US WRONGLY ASSUMED
THAT OUR BILL OF RIGHTS WOULD
PREVENT THEM FROM GOING TOO FAR.
THAT WAS OUR BACKSTOP AGAINST
TYRANNY BUT WE WERE WRONG.
THE BILL OF RIGHTS HAS NOT
PREVENTED THEM FROM DOING
PRECISELY WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
IN STATE AFTER STATE, GOVERNORS
HAVE TARGETED THE FAITHFUL ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT MOST
TRADITIONAL CHRISTIANS DO NOT
VOTE DEMOCRAT, THEREFORE THEY
MUST BE PUNISHED.
BANNING THE EXERCISE OF RELIGION
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL, OBVIOUSLY.
IT’S A DIRECT VIOLATION OF THE
LETTER AND THE SPIRIT OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT’S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE, BUT
THEY HAVE MADE IT HAPPEN.
THEY’VE DONE IT ANYWAY.
AS IN CHINA, OUR GOVERNMENT HAS
ENTHUSIASTICALLY PERSECUTED
CHRISTIANS.
HERE’S NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR PHIL
MURPHY EXPLAINING IT.
>> YOU HAVE CLOSED CHURCH
SERVICES AND SYNAGOGUE SERVICES
INTERESTED PEOPLE FOR ATTEMPTING
TO ATTEND THEM.
DID ANYONE SAY THAT MAY BE
PRACTICING YOUR FAITH MIGHT BE
IMPORTANT TO SOMEONE’S MENTAL
HEALTH?
>> LISTEN, I THINK WE’VE HAD A
VERY GOOD, GOOD COMMON GROUND
WITH FAITH LEADERS OF LITERALLY
EVERY FAITH WHO UNDERSTAND THIS.
>> Tucker: SO LISTEN
CAREFULLY, GOVERNOR MURPHY SAYS
HE’S REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH
THOSE FAITH LEADERS WHO
"UNDERSTAND THIS."
HE DOESN’T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
THE FAITH LEADERS WHO "DON’T
UNDERSTAND THIS."
THE LEADERS WHO WOULD INSTEAD
LIKE TO WORSHIP THEIR GOD AT THE
CONSTITUTION GUARANTEES THEY CAN
THERE IS NO COMMON GROUND FOR
THEM.
THEY WILL BE ARRESTED, JUST AS
THEY ARE IN CHINA.
NOR CAN THEY FIGHT BACK.
IN A FREE SOCIETY, SELF-DEFENSE
IS THE MOST BASIC RIGHT.
ALL OTHER RIGHTS REST UPON IT.
SELF-DEFENSE IS ILLEGAL IN
CHINA.
AND SUDDENLY, IT’S ILLEGAL IN
THIS COUNTRY TOO.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S MILITIA
LOOT STORES, DEFACE OUR CITIES,
ATTACK PEOPLE WITH IMPUNITY BEER
THEY ARE RARELY PUNISHED.
AMERICANS WHO TRY TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES FROM THE VIOLENCE
OF FACE THE FULL RANGE OF THE
STATE.
THEY RISKED GOING TO JAIL, THEY
HAVE BEEN INDICTED.
AS IN CHINA, THERE ARE NOW TWO
STANDARDS OF JUSTICE.
THE PARTY HAS DECIDED WHO CAN BE
ARMED.
EVERYONE ELSE MUST SUBMIT.
IT WASN’T ALWAYS THIS WAY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN FACT, UNTIL RECENTLY, WE HAD
A FUNCTIONING CONSTITUTION, BUT
ANYONE WHO REMEMBERS THAT IS A
THREAT TO THE STATE.
HISTORY ITSELF IS A THREAT TO
THE STATE.
IN CHINA, THERE IS NO HISTORY.
LIKE RELIGION, THE PAST IS
PURELY POLITICAL TOOL SEEKING TO
PROTECT THEIR POWER.
IN PLACE OF GOD, THE STATE
OFFERS SECULAR CULT IN WHICH
CITIZENS WORSHIP A PARTY
APPROVED POLITICAL MURDERS.
IT DOESN’T SOUND VERY AMERICAN,
BUT SUDDENLY IT IS.
>> WE ARE HERE TO HONOR GEORGE
FLOYD.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO, WE WILL
NOW KNEEL FOR OUR MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
>> Tucker: ANYONE WHO
CHALLENGES THE COLT WHO REFUSES
TO JOIN IT, WHO WON’T KNEEL
BEFORE IT IS PUNISHED, AND
THEN THEIR COMPLAINTS ARE
SCRUBBED FROM THE PERMANENT
RECORD.
CHINA DOES THIS.
CHINESE CENSORS SCOUR THE
INTERNET TO MAKE SURE DANGEROUS
IDEAS NEVER MAKE IT TO THE
PUBLIC.
DOES THAT SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU?
THAT IS WHERE OUR TECH OLIGARCHS
LEARNED IT.
THE UNITED STATES, IN OTHER
WORDS, VERY CLEARLY IS BECOMING
VERY MUCH LIKE CHINA AT VERY
HIGH SPEEDS.
IT DOESN’T MEAN THE TWO
COUNTRIES ARE IDENTICAL.
THERE IS STILL REAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THEM.
IN CHINA, FOR EXAMPLE, LEADERS
STILL THINK BEYOND THE NEXT
ELECTION.
THEY DON’T HAVE REAL ELECTIONS,
SO THEY CAN TAKE A LONG TERM
VIEW.
IN CHINA, THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
COUNTRIES IN WHICH THE
POPULATION IS DIVIDED AGAINST
ITSELF, COUNTRIES IN WHICH
CITIZENS HAVE NOTHING MEANINGFUL
IN COMMON WITH ONE ANOTHER ARE
WEAK COUNTRIES.
AND OVER TIME, COUNTRIES LIKE
THAT ARE DOOMED.
ANSWER CHINA EMPHATICALLY
REJECTS IDENTITY POLITICS.
IT’S A LEGAL APPEAR TO LEADERS
IN CHINA DON’T NARROWCAST TO
TINY CONSTITUENCIES BASED ON
THEIR "IDENTITY."
THE IDEA IS APPALLING TO THEM.
THE CHINESE FOCUS INSTEAD ON
NATIONAL IDENTITY.
THEY DON’T WORSHIP DIVERSITY,
THEY PROMOTE UNITY AND THAT IS
WHY LONG TERM, THEY BELIEVE THEY
WILL WIN.
THE CHINESE ALSO BELIEVE, AND
THIS IS ANOTHER STRIKING
DIFFERENCE, THAT THEIR ECONOMY
IS WORTH SAVING.
THEY DIDN’T DESTROY IT WITH
CORONAVIRUS QUARANTINES, HARSH
AS THEY WERE.
UNLIKE THE UNITED STATES, CHINA
WAS A POOR PLACE UNTIL FAIRLY
RECENTLY.
AND SO THEY KNOW FIRSTHAND THAT
POOR COUNTRIES ARE POWERLESS,
AND THEY DON’T WANT THAT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CHINESE CARE